THE EXACT  A CHANGE.
KUZNETSOV AN FEHERVARY THIS PUC.
GOOD HEADS UP PLAY BY CARLSON.
HE EVEN HAD THE LEFT LEGEGM JOH
THE POWER PLAY, AND IT IS 2-0,
CARLSON MOVES TO THE MIDDLE OF
THE ICICTHERED IN THE
CORNER.
HELD IN BY HEDMAN.
AND NOT THE SAME POSITION
WITHOUT THAT STICK.
HIM.
BRAYDEN POINT, BACK.
OH, WHAT A SAVE FROM SAMSONOV.
AND THEY 26.
OTHERWISE, MY GOODNESS, IT WOULD
BE A 2-2 GAME.
KUCHEROV DOES NOT GET HIS STICK
ALEXANDETHE FIRMNESS
OF THE STICK, THE CURVATURUSHET.
>> Brendan: CARLSON WITH A QUICK
THREE POINTSE GROUP FOR THE
WE HAVE GOT CHIRPING GOING ON N
HERE.
THERE IS THE GOAL AT THE END
OFFSIDE.
BUT EVEN IVIE SAYS IT IS GOOD.
>> Brendan: BOY, THAT'S TIGHT.
>> Darren: THAT IS FEET.
HERE'S CARLSON.
HE SCORES!
SECOND GOAL, FOURTH POINT EEN I?
MAYBYB
CIRELLI.
IT IS COLTON.
SERGACHEV.
BACK TO COLTONTHE RIGHT
SIDE WITH COREY PERRY.
WATCH THE EYES AND THE HEAD D
TAMPA BAY LIGHTNIN